hey everyone welcome to the Google Intel
webinar on the IOT platform we're gonna
start the webinar here in a second and
while it's running if you have any
questions just ask them into the live
chat and we'll get to them when it's
done in the meantime enjoy the webinar
[Music]
hey everyone thank you for tuning into
our first show in a three-part series
I'm Gabe Weiss and I work for Google as
a developer advocate for the cloud
platform hi and i'm martin Kronberg from
intel I'm a Technical Evangelist working
with our Internet of Things technologies
and integrating them with cloud partners
such as Google so you know I've been
working on creating proof of concepts as
well as a series of workshops that we're
going to be teaching in the near future
and I'm really excited to share what
I've learned with a broader audience
through these webinars so today we're
going to be discussing how we can use
Intel and Google technologies to create
a predictive maintenance framework
predictive maintenance is a concept of
predicting when a component in a factory
or an airplane is gonna fail and then
replacing it before it does it's based
around gathering as much data as
possible from the system and then using
machine learning to at first find
anomalies in the data and then predict
the nominees in that data before they
happen in this first webinar we're going
to look at the basics Intel and Google's
place in the IOT ecosystem gathering the
sensor data and ingesting the sensor
data into Google's cloud platform so in
order to build out this framework we're
gonna be leveraging Intel IOT hardware
Google's cloud IOT platform as well as
big data processing and machine learning
services in the Google cloud and
hopefully we can inspire you guys to
start some of your own IOT projects
so before we launch into the specifics
of the framework let's take a minute for
a higher level overview of both Intel
and Google's place in the IOT ecosystem
so Martin why do you start and give us a
rundown rundown of what Intel is doing
in IOT space sure well so IOT starts
with endpoints so things like sensors
actuators the kinds of devices that
gather data and then interface with the
environment in some way
the simplest example might be a
thermometer to read temperature and then
a relay to turn on an HVAC system now at
the other end of the spectrum are the
cloud-based analytics big data
processing machine learning natural
language processing and this is where a
lot of the really exciting possibilities
are like printer maintenance but the
thing about machine learning is that
while it has this huge potential across
almost all industries it's very compute
intensive so much so that doesn't really
make sense to run it locally and we have
to run it in the cloud but however once
we leverage those cloud services that
thermostat can all of a sudden do more
than just tell you the temperature right
now it can begin to tell you the
temperature in the future using
predictive analytics you know of course
all these things need a way to talk to
that cloud service right and so there's
a few issues I need to be overcome in
order to make this happen
first of all many endpoints do not have
a way to connect to the internet on
their own now they might have a serial
connection like USB Modbus or maybe a
short-range radio like ZigBee ziwei
bluetooth and so this is where one of
the core aspects of the Intel IOT
ecosystem or the Gateway comes into play
it acts like a data collection hub it
collects all the data from the sensors
and then establishes a secure connection
to the cloud now having a sexual data
collection point like this allows for a
few other things to happen first even if
we could connect each one of these
sensors individually up to the cloud it
would be inefficient as well as insecure
the more connection points that you have
in an IOT system the larger that
potential cyber attack surface becomes
the Gateway minimizes the number of
connections and it also comes with some
security software that makes that
connection as secure as possible so it
makes sense when you talk about these
gateways are you thinking of a specific
device all right so there's a lot of
companies out there that make these
gateway type devices and they're gonna
range in both performance price size as
well as the kinds of i/o that they have
however for this webinar we're gonna be
focusing on the Gateway that comes with
the Grove IOT development kit and it is
an atom powered Nook and this developer
kit is part of a larger developer
program at Intel our developer program
is really aimed at getting all the tools
that outtie developers might need as
well as all the information that they
need to use them in one place we have
libraries code samples even market
studies of different verticals as well
as community forums and all kinds of
training materials like this very
webinar and I would recommend that
anyone interested in learning more about
IOT development go to software TOCOM
slash IOT and check it out
so to facilitate these devices talking
to the cloud Google has created a new
Google cloud platform product cloud IOT
core it's aimed at communicating with
and managing these fleets of devices
it's not to say that it doesn't work for
individual tinker's as well but the
focus really is at these large
installations the planet scale as we
like to say cloud IOT core is a fully
managed service so no need to spin
anything up it just works and scales and
balances internally there's two pieces
to it first is the device manager which
handles registering tracking and
configuring these devices themselves
second is the communication piece which
uses an mqtt or HTTP bridge so DCP
provides an MPEG broker to send data to
right although it's not a fully feature
broker there's no configuration you can
do to the broker communication part it
just passes the payload on to our
messaging system cloud pub/sub that's
what we call it a bridge and not a
broker so on the device management side
IOT core organizes devices into buckets
we call registries each registry map's
one
to a particular pub/sub bucket called a
topic so any devices in a given registry
will have all their messages published
to the Associated pub/sub topic there's
not really enough time in this webinar
to go into all the things you can do
with these devices but to touch on some
of it you can pass configuration
messages back to the devices from IOT
core you can enable or disable a device
assign properties to individual devices
or control the SSL key expiration for
security and more so then does GCP
automatically refresh the SSL
certificates that are needed for the
connection not automatically know so
best practice is when the device gets
created you install a number of
certificates and then in the IOT core
interface you can specify timeouts for
individual certs to do the rotation it's
easier than having to flash new starts
to the device after it's already
installed somewhere possibly hard to get
to so on that communication side
messages are handled simply with mqtt
being the dominant protocol devices can
send messages to the IOT core endpoint
which then publishes their payload to
the next link in the chain cloud pub/sub
well talk in more detail about what you
can do with these messages once they hit
pub/sub in the next webinar
the biggest takeaway here is the pub/sub
scales globally each topics available
from anywhere in the world and can
handle over a million messages per
second so you never have to worry about
your devices overloading the system wow
that's a pretty impressive bandwidth is
there a size limit to the individual
messages there is 256 K which for
devices is a lot of sensor data but
depending on the device being used I'd
never go that high network usage is one
of the biggest drains on power for these
small devices that size is more for the
use case of like a device that would
sleep for a long time
gather a bunch of data wake up and
deliver it in the big bursts and then go
back to sleep for a long time
cool well let's take a look at this
framework so first we have a few sensors
here so we have a light sensor we have a
sound sensor and we have a temperature
sensor these types of sensors are used
typically in industrial environments to
monitor machinery or various processes
the sensors that we're going to be using
are these Grove prototyping sensors
which are plugged into an arduino 101
which we're using as a sensor hub these
sensors are really great for quickly
prototyping or creating a
proof-of-concept they each have a socket
which gives you power ground and then 2
signal pins so there's no need for bread
boarding these sensors in particular
came from the IOT developer kit which I
mentioned earlier the aruna 101 is
connected to our dough gateway via a USB
we're gonna be using the Fermata
protocol in order to pass data between
the arduino 101 and the Gateway
essentially for moderate virtualizes the
GPIO is on the Arduino allowing full
control from the gateway now on the
gateway we're going to be using a Python
script to gather the sensor data package
that data into JSON objects and then
connect to Google Cloud to send data
back and forth so how do you interface
with the sensors on the Gateway are
there libraries that you're using yeah
so specifically we're going to be using
M raw and upm M raw is a low-level
sensor library created and maintained by
Intel for interfacing with GPIO s I
squared C buses and SP is just to give
you an idea of how all this works here's
a sample of code that we're gonna be
using in this project basically we're
using M rod to connect to the Arduino
using the generic firmata protocol and
then we're using upm to create three
sensor objects sound light temperature
and then using the sensor API reader
value to read out the sensor values
pretty simple and what's really cool
about Emraan upm is that these libraries
are a hundred percent open source and
they're compatible with almost all
developer platforms so you can run Emre
on Raspberry Pi Beagle bone
all the Intel gateway platforms up
squared board middle board it even works
with some Altera FPGAs so once again as
a developer you're gonna have a lot of
flexibility you can start developing on
whatever platform you have access to and
then if you decide that you need to move
over to Intel Architecture you can take
your code as is for the most part and
deploy it on a different platform to
befriend there's going to be some
translation needed from platform to
platform for instance not all devices
are going to deploy a USB to the tty a
cm0 node as a gateway has so once the
sensor data is clicked in the gateway
then we need to get it to the cloud this
starts with the devices implementing
that MQTT protocol to send messages MQTT
stands for message queue telemetry
transport and it's a very lightweight
publish/subscribe protocol that sits on
top of tcp/ip it's ideal for the IOT
world because it's so efficient it works
with the low level low powered devices
without draining power too fast to talk
over MQTT to cloud IOT core developers
need to use a library in the language
they're using on the device there's good
ones for Python and nodejs that I've
used there's also a C library called
PAHO MQTT so there's no need for any
kind of special GCP SDK or library is
there one even available and not for the
transmission of messages no but the
whole point was we were aiming it make
it as easy as possible for the devices
so it's just this Google endpoint for
MQTT messages and that's it the managed
service then handles the rest once we
send the message in the proper protocol
that next piece is going to be
authentication IOT core authenticates
devices using jot JSON web tokens I'm
not going to go into a lot of but a lot
of detail about it but we can include a
link to more information about it the
TLDR version is that it's an encoded
claim encrypted with the public private
key pair using either RSA or ECC that's
transmitted as a JSON object once you've
got that taken care of it's time to
start sending the data the message
payloads can be whatever you want most
of our examples use JSON blobs of sensor
data because it's really easy to pull
JSON directly into downstream pipelines
without too much extra
there's a few limitations around the
messages like that 256k size that we
mentioned limits are listed clearly in
the docs though on the cloud side to get
all the set up you need to have an
account on GCP with the cloud IOT core
enabled and from there you can create
your device registry which is tied to
the pub subtopic and once that registry
is created then you can register all
your devices with SSL keys and that's it
to get your basics up and running well
you know that sounds pretty
straightforward is there a place where
developers can go to find a step-by-step
tutorial for starting their own project
totally so if you go to google clouds
website cloud google.com click on the
documentation and there's a link to
everything right there all right well
let's take a look at some code and
figure out how all the stuff actually
works all right so for the code there's
the two pieces that I've talked about
before the token creation and the MQTT
client initialization so for the jaw
token I'm highlighting here this is
really all of the code it is very tight
so for jots there's three properties
that we're sending for our tokens
there's an initialization time an
expiration time and then it's called an
audience key and the audience key is how
the receiver knows what's being
authenticated in our case it's the ID
for the project that we created in the
Google cloud platform so as Intel
webinar is our project name right then
we can see here we're grabbing the
private key which lives on the device
itself that's what was flashed onto the
device and that gets encrypted with the
jaw and then we encode it and send it
with in our case we're using the RSA
algorithm so that's it for the jaw
chokan the next piece is this MQTT
client initialization and that's this
hunk down here below and all it is it's
initializing the MQTT client with an ID
and that ID is this super long URL which
is the ID for this individual device in
Google cloud platform that we registered
and then an mqtt topic which is how the
endpoint in Google Cloud knows where to
send your
individual what what bucket in pub/sub
that it's going to end up identifying
with so the device is associated with
the registry the registry is associated
with the pub subtopic and that's how it
knows how to where to put that message
from there we established our username
password and for our password it is that
jot token that we created above and a
couple of callbacks so we can just track
what's going on with the the client as
it's doing its thing and then we set the
TLS so the TLS is so that the MQTT
communication is authenticated on both
sides so the device is registered with
our ssl key that's how the Google side
knows the device is talking to it on the
flipside the device needs to be assured
that it's actually talking to Google for
that we've retrieved a root certificate
from Google and that's how then the
device knows it's talking to the cloud
service appropriately from there this is
the mqtt endpoint that Google has
created MQTT Google API is calm and
that's how it knows where to send the
messages to and that's it for the cloud
communication all right so then once we
establish that cloud communication to
GCP we're just going to be creating a
JSON object that has as you guys can see
a timestamp the temperature the sound
and the light values from our sensors
and we're getting the temperature the
sound and the light values using those
upm libraries that i mentioned earlier
we're publishing this to our
mqtt topic and we're doing this once a
second basically continuously until we
shut this script down and that's all
that you really need in order to create
the connection and then start sending
data to GCP so that's it for the basics
thanks everyone for joining us today and
learning about Intel devices and
starting to connect to Google's cloud
platform with those devices tune in to
our next webinar to learn about how the
messages from pub/sub can be fed into
Google's data pipeline to be analyzed
and queried thanks everyone and we'll
see you next time
you
you
hey everybody welcome back to the Google
Studios we're here live and I am deep in
chef I'm at a Google cloud executive and
you know Gabe from the webinar gaben and
I are here to answer any questions you
guys have I really appreciate you adding
all those comments in the comments
section and we have other ones that
we've also gathered from folks so we're
gonna go ahead and start with some Q&A
sounds good so one of the questions was
I built a prototype with an IOT device
how can I share my ideas with the GCP
developers and I'd love to get their
opinions mm-hmm so the best way probably
is to reach out there's a contact us so
if you are on your console and GCP the
hamburger menu up on the top left you
drop it down there's a support item
there and there's a link directly the
community support and that will reach
out to not just those of us at Google
for the GCP developers but also our
extended network the G DG's and just the
greater community so there will be a lot
of good feedback for your device there
great that's a there's a really handy
console in there the other question is
is the code showing now available on
github soon so it's not available on
github yet I'm gonna put it up there on
mine but there's code that's very
similar to it on the IOT core Docs so if
you go into cloud Google comm and click
on the IOT core there's a section in
there about MQTT client samples and the
sample this there has essentially the
code that we've been showing here
amazing amazing work you guys are doing
how much does it cost is a question that
comes up often so it's actually free to
start it's 250 megabytes is free and
then from there it's a tiered pricing
plan it's available online and you'll be
able to see it the tiers online so once
you log in we can you can also contact
sales where there's a button down there
to ask any other questions related to it
so the biggie is that because it's
serverless you're paying for what you
use so you're basically paying for
network traffic only yeah you mentioned
that
IOT core supports both MQTT and HTTP in
the video which one should they use
so it really depends on your use case
broadly speaking what like my gut take
on IOT in general use MQTT HTTP sends a
lot of extra stuff along with the
transmission all your headers and all of
that so since you're paying for the
amount of data that you transmit HTTP on
the long term is going to cost you more
it also because you're sending more data
it's battery consumption the biggest
killer of these devices is going to be
network traffic so the more traffic you
send the mote with quicker it's gonna
drain your battery on these devices so
MQTT is becoming basically the de facto
standard in the industry so that's what
we suggest right right so the other one
is what kind of quality of service do
you support for the MQTT protocol right
so there there's three different levels
of service for those that don't know
about quality of service there's no
guarantee that the message got sent so
you just kind of fire it off into the
internet and pray that it gets to where
it needs to go there's guaranteed at
least once
and there's guaranteed once and only
once so the levels that we support are
that fire-and-forget
level 0 and level 1 which is at least
once we don't support level 2 which is
the once and only once the performance
hit on it isn't scaleable and it won't
work well with IOT devices another
question that just popped up thank you
for asking the question do you have
setup procedures for this as far as
getting started with this no because
it's a server list setup as long as
you've got your GCP project set up
you're basically good to go and that
hamburger menu drop down all the way
down there's IOT core listed and you
should have it in the console and you
can just get started right away creating
your registry registering your devices
like we described and away you go
you shouldn't have to do anything more
it should already be enabled it might be
a good plug there's also subsequent
webinars coming up to show you different
levels of the IOT core platform right so
this one in this webinar we covered the
Intel hardware devices and how to get
them talking to the GCP in that initial
IOT core piece and then the next webinar
coming up we're going to cover more
information about pub/sub our messaging
system and into bigquery which is it's
going to be very cool and then the third
one come
after is going to be on machine learning
so stay tuned for our next webinars
coming up graduates we appreciate the
comments and the feedback we're glad it
helped I think the last question was
very similar to the other one is what do
I need to get started and if you just
answered that so it's great anything
else I think that's it so like we said
stay tuned for the next webinars thank
you everyone for tuning into this and
we'll see you next time
appreciate your time Thanks